Miami is known as the Gateway to the
Americas a fact that's helped the city
grow over the last few decades foreign
investment is a major contributor to
South Florida's economy but the US
government says it can come with a
downside money laundering is is designed
to hide and play in plain sight
Andrew ittle minh specializes in anti
money laundering laws and says Venezuela
is a big offender with a socialist
government that had held itself out as
providing for these people for
everything that they need and then the
people who were in charge of making sure
that that happened ended up being
corrupted and taking the money for
themselves out of the country while the
images of everything that's happening in
Venezuela is on international TV as a
humanitarian an economic situation in
Venezuela continues to decline the cases
of government officials prosecuted for
money laundering as stacking up the
Brazilian backed Odebrecht construction
project was abandoned over corruption
allegations two years ago when it was
revealed that almost a hundred million
dollars was paid out to Venezuelan
officials almost 200,000 people lost
their jobs when the project stalled but
it's real estate deals in the US that
are coming under increasing federal
scrutiny developers and realtors like
Jesse Otley are aware of the problem in
South Florida and say they're more
discerning with buyers than ever before
our brand is important the brand of
Miami is important our developers
credibility and their brands are very
important as well so so that you know
those reasons make us very aware of who
we're dealing with and how we're dealing
with them the problem of money
laundering operations investing in the
US isn't restricted to Venezuela in 2016
the Panama papers scandal revealed a
network of officials from across the
world using shell corporations and real
estate deals to hide cash and lead
luxury lifestyles real estate
transactions in Florida and now a major
focus for the FBI even as political
tensions between the u.s. and Venezuela
escalate it's an issue the bureau is now
pouring more resources into an
indication of just how serious the
problem is Florida has a reputation as a
haven for money laundering but the
concentration on Venezuela is brought
into sharp focus when people are
suffering such serie
hardships US officials say they'll
continue to seize assets monitor
transactions and clamp down on the
practice earlier this year the FBI
opened its first permanent
anti-corruption unit here in South
Florida critics say it should have
happened years ago but agents have
already seized several properties in the
last few weeks and a Gallacher al
Jazeera Miami Florida